foreign
hi Dr deloney how are you I'm good how
are you
all right something must be wrong with
having the name Kelly because my furnace
went my hot water heater went and I
needed new tires good grief man your
furnace and your hot water
yeah my furnace hot water heater and my
tires which it was like three degrees
like a couple weeks ago so I was worried
about my pipes freezing and
yeah there's no bueno man you got it
worked out
what's that you got it worked out
yeah good good good good all right so
what's up how can I help
yeah so uh my question is do I wait for
my husband to make a decision regarding
the future of our marriage or do I call
it quits
tell me more
yeah
so we dated for four years and we've
been married for six years uh we have a
six-year-old daughter okay just a little
bit of background uh in April 2021 I had
an affair uh he discovered this via text
uh he moved out uh we're still currently
separated but that's kind of a long
story
um I continue to see the new guy for a
year and then broke things off with him
so this wasn't just a hookup this is
like you you found somebody new
right what did this dude uh just this is
an aside what did this but it will loop
back around what did this person bring
you
um you've talked about that high and
feeling alive
um that was one thing
um I was uh
uh shoot sorry
um he paid attention to me
um validated me
um Mutual interests
we work together which talked about that
a lot
um
so so your husband finds out
um he steps away you continue this
relationship
um and then it eventually breaks up how
and y'all are still talking to me and
your husband y'all never got divorced
right uh we were looking to file
he is he was seeing someone else as well
during
um that year like that I was and then we
both around the same time it was kind of
weird
um stopped seeing other people and now
we're trying to rekindle our marriage
um uh we went to marriage counseling he
initiated that and then I started going
to like one-on-one counseling through
better help and I'm still doing that and
then at marriage counseling it was
pretty cool because
we voiced our needs
um
which was kind of a long process
um did they start just just as an aside
did they start with
um I need you to stop having sex with
other people that aren't me
was that one of them uh no
well I mean it wasn't I mean we got into
the entire Story entire and just what
I'm just wondering if that was because
if I'm in your if either one of your
shoes that would have been like my
second or third need probably top three
yeah I mean it wasn't yeah it wasn't
said as directly sorry it caught me off
guards but uh yes all right
so um oh so you're in marriage
counseling and it's clearly not going
well so fast forward to now
is he just falling off the map
exactly yeah um are y'all still living
apart
we are
um part of that is
uh we were talking about me selling my
house moving in with him and he made the
comment at marriage counseling that uh
he would keep the house in his name in
case I cheated again he would kick me
out yeah this like like your your
marriage is over
it's over
it's it's it's done and now
he sounds like he's unable to
to say it's over and so he's just gonna
let it run out of air I run out of gas
and when that happens it's very hard to
be
to to make rational adult decisions when
you resent each other and the longer
this thing just gets suffocated or just
runs out of gas
um and the cars just driving I mean just
rolling down the road it's not even
driving anymore uh man the Messier your
co-parenting gets the Messier decisions
you stop you start you stop not liking
each other and you start hating each
other
and tell me I'm wrong
no you're right I mean it sounds it
sounds oh yeah is he pulling back and
and withdrawn
yes and he's actually started I uh
discovered text messages that well I
didn't see them but he was texting the
girl he was with prior
um and I straight up asked him if he was
interested in her and he said no but
when I asked him about us if you want to
still be with me uh he said I don't know
I can't seem to get over what you did
yeah that's fair and so I here's the
deal you all need to go out to a
grown-up lunch or grown-up breakfast
and call it because here's the deal
you've got you've got a kid who's
absorbing all of this
right and
um
y'all are being cruel to her you're
being cruel to your each other
don't you think
yeah at some point and neither of you
want to you don't want to have been the
person who cheated and ruined your
marriage you don't want that right
um your husband doesn't want to have
been a guy that got cheated on
and y'all don't want to your daughter to
grow up in a divorce household you don't
want all these things yet here we are
and so this the sooner you can own
reality and acknowledge reality and then
begin to live with that understanding
the the
faster people will heal and the better
chances you'll have of being acting like
mature adults down the road yeah that
becomes does that make sense
yeah
so somebody's got to call it
okay
and if you sit down and say I'm asking
you to make a decision right now are we
done
um
and if he says well I still I don't know
it you need to have a decision
okay and if you get in this well I'm not
doing it well you're I'm not doing it I
mean come on man we got to be grown-ups
at this point you gotta you got a kid
right right and you'll have to make
decisions with what comes next
um it sounds like he's called it quits
he just hasn't said it out loud yet
right
okay I'm sorry
thank you yeah are you at a place where
you've forgiven yourself
foreign
working on it okay some days are better
than others yeah it'll take a season
and he's not blameless either yeah
what have you learned in this situation
uh
I take care of myself because
I'm used to
you know putting other people first and
then I realize I have needs and then I
make
for decisions so more of a balance
I think if you were to be honest about
your needs and have the courage to voice
them as you need them not wait till they
all pile up and then oh yeah definitely
pile up that makes it and becomes
insurmountable and then some sweet
talking dude who just wants to hook up
with you at work
um
is able to
cut your values off at the roots right
right
yeah your your values are worth being
spoken out loud
I hope you'll take that with you
yeah is that fair
yep the end of this even though it feels
like it's yellow I mean you haven't
separated what a year now two years
or I guess a year and a half
yeah a year and a half yep okay
um
the finality will feel like a death
it will hit you harder than you think
it's going to
okay
because there's part of you the things
I've been living with this I've we've
kind of been practicing being divorced
right and kid going back and forth and
all that it will be a whole other layer
when this thing is finalized or when
somebody says
I'm gonna do this let's do a no fault
divorce so it's not drama we're not
causing problems we're not splitting up
everything I'm not gonna sue you or
whatever we're going to be adults about
this we're gonna have a no fault and
we're gonna sign it up and we're gonna
then be great co-parents
um
and we're not going to give all of our
money to attorneys and when the moment
you do that it's going to be heavy
um
and y'all both might sit there and weep
at the at the lunch table
right
is it fair
yeah and here's what I want you to also
do this I want you to have just in case
just in case
you sit down for breakfast or lunch and
you say hey are we done
and he looks at you and says absolutely
not
it's 2023 I'm Coming Out Swinging for my
new Merit for my marriage we're gonna
make it new I'm not giving up on this
thing I'm all in I want you to have a
list of things five things ten things
here's what I need from you moving
forward we have to live in the same
house we get a share bank account you
got to be all in you got to put both
feet in this thing I'm going to put both
feet in this thing and that means you
can get hurt again and I can get hurt
again
but that's the only way we can go
forward
you tell me what you need
I'll open up all my text messages I
won't text another person I'm not
married to I I like whatever we need to
do
fabulous just in case
but it sounds like this thing is over it
needs somebody who's an adult to say all
right what are we going to do next just
about owning reality
I'm sorry that you're here
I hope that 2023 is a year of healing
for you
healing always starts with telling the
truth on a reality and asking that one
terrifying question